[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه والتي نستعرض
ونرصد معكم ابرز الاخبار والمستجدات في
العناوين
الرئيس الصيني يبدا زياره الرسميه
للسعوديه تستمر ثلاثه ايام وتتخللهما
قمتان خليجيه وعربيه
بعد حل شرطه الاخلاق يحاول تهدئه
الاحتجاجات مجددا ويدعو لاصلاح النظام
الثقفي
مصادر تكشف للعربيه رئيس البعثه الامميه
في الحديده النجا باعجوبه من انفجار لغم
حوثي تحت سيارته
في المونديال احتفالات عربيه ومغربيه اسود
الاطلس تصنع التاريخ وتتخطى ثيران اسبانيا
[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم بدعوه من العاهل السعوديه الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز يبدا الرئيس الصيني
سجن بين اليوم زياره الرسميه الى السعوديه
تستمر ثلاثه ايام حيث ستعقد قمه سعوديه
صينيه واخرى خليجيه صينيه وثالثه عربيه
صينيه وسيعقد العاهل السعودي والرئيس
الصيني محادثات رسميه تتناولوا العلاقات
الثنائيه والشراكه الاستراتيجيه التي تجمع
البلدين
واكد السفير الصينيه لدى السعوديه
علاقات الشراكه الاستراتيجيه الشامله وفقه
صحيفه الشرق الاوسط واشار السفير في ذات
الصدد الى ان العالم سيشهد اول قمه تعقد
بين الصين والدول العربيه وبين الصين ودول
مجلس التعاون الخليجي على مستوى القاده
معنى من بكين الصحفي نادر رونج اهلا بك
معنا سيد نادر اذا قمم تعقد لاول مره ماذا
يوجد على اولى جداول او الجدول الصيني
العربيه
التنسيق مواقف السياسيه وكذلك التعاون
والتعميك وتعاون في مجال التجاره
والاقتصاد وكذلك في همم مجال التكنولوجيا
عاليه وغيره من
شانه
التعاون في مجال الطاقه
[موسيقى]
التي تعقد لاول مره سيدنا نادر
اه اه اعتقد من متتابعات هنا من سين من
الصين
تريد التعميق الشراكه
سواء السياسيه والاقتصاديه والتجاريا
الثقافيه مع الدول العربيه وخاصه السعوديه
وكذلك هناك في امكانيه مضحكه
الدول العربيه يمكن ان تكون يعني ماستر
اوتامان
وكذلك الصين يمكن ان تقدم مساعدات في دول
العربيه على
التنميه الاقتصاديه
وتطور بشكل مستقيم
مستقل
همم
الدول العربيه وخاصه الدول الخليج سياسات
مستقله وكذلك هناك التعامل العربي من في
يا الله مثل
التايوان وحقوق الانسان وغيرها من
المجموعه صالح الجوهريه للصين طيب
وفي سبيل تعزيز العلاقات بين البلدان
العربيه والصين ما الذي يمكن ان تقدمه
الصين لهذه الدول
الخليج لانشائي
منطقه تجاره الحره بين الطرفين
اكبر شركه انتجاري لتدور العربيه اللي همم
سنوات طويله وكذلك
سننتقل الى العاصمه الاردنيه عمان
والمؤتمر الثلاثي بين وزراء خارجيه مصر
والاردن والعراق
الى جانب العراق الشرقيه تعني امنه
واستقراره وسيادته ركيزه لامن منطقتنا
وضروره من اجل الحفاظ على الامن
والاستقرار الاقليمي كما تعلمون العراق
الشقيقه
كبيره على العصابات الداعشيه في الماضي
وبدات عمليه البناء وال- والاعمار بشكل
ثابت وواضح
وراينا نجاح هذه العمليه تبدى في المرحله
الاخيره بنجاح العمليه السياسيه وتشكيل
الحكومه الجديده التي نتطلع للعمل معها من
اجل المضيف
عملنا المشترك وتعزيز تعاوننا اتفقنا
اليوم على ان نستمر في الاجتماعات على
مستوى وزراء الخارجي
والاجتماعات القطاعيه ايضا وسنلتقي ان شاء
الله قريبا في بغداد
للتحضير همم
القمه التي ستستضيفها جمهوريه مصر العربيه
الشقيقه ان شاء الله
العام
القادم
ولقائنا اليوم كان ايضا فرصه للحديث حول
حديد قضايا اقليميه في اطار عمليه التشاور
والتنسيق المستمر بيننا وركزنا همم كما هو
متوقع بدايه على قضيتنا المركزيه الاولى
القضيه الفلسطينيه
جهدنا المشترك لحل اللازمات الاقليميه
وتحقيق الامن والاستقرار في المنطقه نحن
معضون
سيدنا مستمرون في العمل المؤسسات العمليه
المنهج من اجل ان نخدم مصالحنا المشتركه
وكما اكدنا دائما اليه التعاون الثلاثي هي
اليه لخدمه مصالحنا المشتركه ولخدمه العمل
العربي المشترك
وخطوه على طريق تفعيل العمل العربي
المشترك وهي اليه نرى فيها نفعا لدولنا
ونرى فيها نفعا للمنطقه ومفتوحه على كل
اشقاء الذين يرونه ايضا نفعا لهم في العمل
همم في ايطاليا
مره اخرى ارحب بصاحبي المعالي همم
اجتمعنا اليوم
اجتماع الناجحا اكد اننا نريد ان نستمر في
العمل معا بدا اننا نريد ان نستمر في
التعاون والتنسيق والتشاور اكد ان مصالحنا
مشتركه وان
هدفنا واحد وهو خدمه قضايانا العربيه
وخدمه مصالحنا وخدمه الامن والاستقرار في
المنطقه ارحب بكم مره اخرى صاحب المعاني
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اخي العزيز معالي
الوزير ايمن اخي العزيز
همم هذا همم الجو الاخو الذي يجمعنا
اليه عمل الثلاثي لي المقام الاول للهدف
منها هو عزيز الروابط القائمه بالفعل في
ما بين الدول الثلاثه الاعتماد على
التكامل الذي
يقوم فيما بينهما والفرس المتاحه
الاقتصاديه وايضا المجال التنسيق والتبادل
الرؤى سهلا بالقضايا الاقليميه ولتحقيق
الاستقرار
والعمل المشترك على تحقيق المصالح فيما
بيننا نحن
بفضل توجهات القاده نعمل على توصيل حلاقه
على استكشاف مواضع
التعاون التي تصب في مصلحه الشعوب بلدان
الثلاث ونستمر في ايضا العمل على
التنسيق الوثيق ودعم
العراقيه واستمرار العراق مكون رئيسي في
همم اطار العمل العربي المشترك تدعيم
الاستقرار في المنطقه ال- همم ان شاء الله
مجالات التعاون اللي سبق وان تم نقولها في
ما بين الدول الثلاثاء والاجراءات التي
تتخذ
وضعها موضع التنفيذ كانت محل نقشنا اليوم
تستمر في
التواصل كما تفضل اخي علي الوزير ايمن
تمام مره اخرى في العراق
المعنيين في المجلات الفنيه
لاسترجاع كل الخطوات التي اتخذت وايضا
تناول ما نحتاج الى عمله لدفع خدمه بتنفيذ
هذه
المشروعات المختلفه وايضا
اسراف
مجالات التعاون الاخرى التي قد نطلع بها
ال- همم المرحله القادمه بالتاكيد همم
الدول الثلاثه واجهه تحديات عديده مرتبطه
بال- جو همم
سياسي القائم الضغوط الاقتصاديه المترتبه
على الازمه الاوكرانيه
وال امن الغذائي وامن الطاقه وما يفرضوا
من تحدي كل ذلك يعزز من الحاجه الى مزيد
من التعاون فيما بيننا لمواجهه هذه
التحديات
وبالتاكيد انه التضامن
والعمل المشترك من شان انه ان يزيد من
قدرتنا على ذلك همم سوف نستمر ان شاء الله
في غلطنا ونعمل بان همم يكون هذا الاطار
نموذج لتوسيع ايضا العمل العربي المشترك
بصفه عامه
وسوف نستمر همم باطار
ان هذا هو عمل ليس الهدف منه الا تحقيق
المصلحه وليس
باي حال من الاحوال الغرض منه اي نوع من
قصر العمل وانما توسعته
وتفاعل مع بقيه الاطراف
الدول العربيه اول مستوى الاقليمي امر
يهمنا نعمل
اوائده مباشره على المواطنين وعلى تحقيق
الاستقرار وعلى
الاء
على اساس الاحترام المتبادل
الارضيه المشتركه التي تجمع شكرا جزيلا
شكرا جزيلا
مع الاخ ايمن علي
حسن الاستقبال وكرامه الضيافه وايضا نشكر
على عقد هذا الاجتماع وتناول
مجموعه من المواضيع التي تهم الدول
الثلاثه
اليه العمل المشترك الاتي هي اليه تعود
الى حكومه الاخ عادل عبد المهدي
مرورا بحكومه الاخ مصطفى الكاظمي من ناحيه
من جانب العراق
همم نستند اليها للعمل المشترك في مجالات
مختلفه سواء المجله الاقتصادي
الشيخ ياسين
والعمل المشترك في المجال الدولي
وتم
في هذا الاجتماع مناقشه مجموعه من
المواضيع
له علاقه بخاصه المشاريع الاقتصاديه
بالاضافه الى ايضا التطرف الى
القمه او مؤتمر بغداد النسخه الثانيه
والذي ينعقد
في عمان في 20 من هذا الشهر وايضا تمت
الاشاره في اجتماعاتنا اليوم ثمانيه اشاره
الى
اجتماع القمه العربيه الصينيه
الرياض
هذه الاهليه مهمه
لاستمراريه العمل وتستند الى ايضا منطلقات
عراقيه السياسه الخارجيه العراقيه تستند
الى
خلق حاله التوازن في العلاقات وخاصه في
العلاقات مع الدول الجوار
وسياسه الخارجيه العراقيه تهتم كثيرا في
تقويه العلاقات مع جميع الدول العراقيه
فهذه الاليه ضمن علاقات اولا دول الجوار
العراقي ولكن ايضا ومن اطار تقويه
التعاون الاقتصادي وهناك تحديات كبيره
تواجهنا كما ذكر تحديات لا علاقه بالامن
الغذائي امن دوائي امن الطاقه هذه
التحديات لانها تحديات كبيره
وتتخطى الحدود الوطنيه نحتاج الى
علاقات اقليميه ودوليه لكي يواجه هذه
المسائل وسوف يتم عقده الاجتماع
قادمه سواء في بغداد او في اماكن اخرى
ونتطلع الى القمه الثلاثيه في القاهره
وشكرا
شكرا عليك معنا وقت ممكن سؤال او سؤالين
سؤالين فقط
بردانه بتحيرونا هيك ههه
يعطيكم العافيه
تنفيذ المشاريع بين الدول الثلاثه على ارض
الواقع
وهل تطورات مشروع الربط الكهربائي هل
المشروع مستخدم فيه الغاز المصري
يعطيكم العافيه
شكرا
العمل على تنفيذ ما اتفق عليه من مشاريع
مستمر وماضي انجزنا الكثير في ما يتعلق
البنيه القانونيه لهذه البشريه والتحضيرات
الاقتصاديه في ما يتعلق في المنطقه
الصناعيه
العمل مستمر وتم توقيع اتفاقيات للمضي بها
الرابطه الكهربائي تم توقيع الاتفاقيه
وبدا العمل على الارض من اجل ربط
الكهربائي كما تعلم هنالك يا رباه قائم ما
بين المملكه وجمهوريه مصر العربيه الشقيقه
الان بدا العمل على الربط الكهربائي ايضا
مع اشقائنا في العراق والهدف هو ان نربط
الشبكات ثلاث حتى يكون هنالك تعاون مستمر
في هذا المجال ايضا على مستوى التعاون
التجاري الاقتصادي ايضا تم توقيع عديد
اتفاقات وبدات تنفيذها في قطاع النقل ايضا
تم تنفيذ التوافق على العديد من المجلات
فبالتالي ال- ال- انجاز مستمر هو متدرج
تمت ظروف سياسيه اقليميه همم
حاله ربما دون ان نمضي بهمم السرعه التي
كنا نريدها اشقائنا في العراق كان عندهم
عمليه سياسيه كان يجب ان تنتهي والحمد لله
انتهت بنجاح حتى نستطيع ان نستعيد الزخم
فبالتالي العمل مستمر للتوافق موجود
التنفيذ بدا بعض المشاريع تاخذ اكثر من
غيرها نتيجه لطبيعتها وظروفها وما تحتاجه
من امكانيات ومن ومن تحضيرات لكن كما قلت
الرؤى واضحه الاراده موجوده همم التعريف
العملي للمشاريع التي فيها فائده مشتركه
تم والانجاز مستمر لكن نتدرج همم فيما
يحقق الفائده من ذلك فبالتالي العمل العمل
ان شاء الله ولا انجاز مستمر
كان ذلك مشاهدينا مؤتمر صحفي بين وزراء
خارجيه مصر والعراق والاردن واشكر ايضا
ضيفي الاستاذ نادر لانضمامه معنا في هذه
النشره حول الملف الصيني بعوده الى سياق
نشرتنا ومع تواصل الاحتجاجات والضغط على
السلطات في مختلف المدير الايرانيه اعلنت
وسائل الاعلام حكوميه ان المرشد الايراني
مع مجلس ثقافيين تابع للدوله على المجلس
الاعلى مراعاه ضعف الثقافه في مجالات
مختلفه في البلاد تصريحات من اي تاتي بعد
ايام من قرار بحل جهاز شرطه الاخلاق في
محاوله لاحتواء تظاهرات والتي تسبب بها
مقتل الشاب نتيجه تعرضها للتعذيب وشهدت
مختلف المدن الايرانيه بالامس اضرابات
لليوم الثاني على التوالي حيث اغلقت عدد
من المحال التجاريه والشركات او اغلقت
ابوابها كما طبعا 5100 من عمال العقود
العاملين في شركه خزانات بتركيا موويات في
جنوب غرب ايران وفي غضون ذلك مشاهدينا
تواصلت التظاهرات في عدد من المدن
الايرانيه لا سيما العاصمه الايرانيه
طيران ومحافظه خراسان وفارس ومشهد شمال
شرقي ايران
[موسيقى]
شيراز
وحول ما يمكن ان تفعله الولايات المتحده
للمحتاجين الايرانيين اشهر السنه
اكثر صراحه في القول انها ستفعل كل ما في
وسعها لعزل النظام الايراني
حتى يتمكنوا من الاستمرار في موازنه ايران
ويمكن للاداره ان توضح اننا لن نتفاوضا مع
ايران ولا ينبغي ان نفعل اي شيء على اي
حال
الى المحتاجين الايرانيين والاشخاص الذين
يحاولون الدفاع عن بعض الشعور بالحريه
خاص للعربيه حول التظاهرات في ايران انه
يجب عزل ايران اكثر واخذ القضيه الى الامم
المتحده الطيران على جميع
ما يراه جرائم حرب ضد الناس قائلا الى
الشعب الايراني يجب ان يسمع صوتنا ق
الامكان واكد السيناتور الامريكي ان الغاء
شرطه الاخلاق يظهروا بعض الدلائل على ان
النظام الايراني يشعر بالفعل بالقلق
فسيقداته اتهم السيناتور الديمقراطي ورئيس
لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه في الكونجرس
الامريكي باب منندز اتهم النظام الايراني
بالاستخفاف وبدمن بارد بحقوق الانسان
مشيرا الى ان طهران تسيء الى النظام
القانوني الايراني وتحكم على المتظاهرين
بالاعدام وتوضح في ذلك ذات الوقت ازدراءها
لاولئك الذين يقاتلونا من اجل مستقبل
ايرانيا خالي من القمع
ومن الاحتياجات في ايران الى التهديدات
الايرانيات لمياه الخليج حيث تهم الجيش
الامريكي البحريه التابعه للحرس الثوري
الايراني بتصرف بشكل غير امن وغير مهني في
مضيقي هرمز قال الجيش الامريكي ان زورقا
للبحريه التابعه للحرس الثوري الايراني
اقترب لمسافه 150 يارده من سفن حربيه
امريكيه في مضيق هرمز لكن تم انهاء الموقف
بعد توجيه تحذيرات صوتيه مشاهدينا
واستخدام غير مميت لليزر واضاف الجيش
الامريكي في بيان ان الحديث وقع في الخامس
من ديسمبر الجاري خلال عمليه عبورتينيه في
المياه الدوليه وفي تصريحات خاصه للعربيه
انتقد وزير خارجيه النمس
بقوه ايران مؤكدا ان علاقات بلاده بها
تغير الجذريا واضاف ان مسيرات طيران
تشاركه في ارتكابي جرائم حرب
طبعا يجب ان يكون موقفنا واضح وعلى ايران
ان تعترف بان المسارات الايرانيه تستخدمها
روسيا في اوكرانيا وهذه المسيارات تستخدم
لرتكاب جرائم حربه واعتقد ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي كان محقا تماما في فرض العقوبات
وسنعمل على اصدار عقوبات اضافيه الاسبوع
المقبل وفيما يخص العلاقات لا يمكن ان
ننظر فقط الى تزويد روسيا بالمسيرات فنحن
نشهد ايضا عمليات قمع مقلقه جدا ضد
تظاهرات الشعب الايراني دمويه النظام
الايراني تجاه شعبه وهنا مره اخرى يجب ان
يكون موقفنا واضحا جدا وعلينا فرد مزيد من
العقوبات
تهديد ومراقبه الايرانيين المقيمين في
كندا رصدها تقرير للمخابرات الكنديه اكد
ان النظام الايراني استخدموا عملاؤه في
كندا لمراقبه مزدوجي الجنسيه وتعزيزها
للكف عن انشطتهم ضد النظام كما فرضت كندا
الالاف من العقوبات على انصار النظام
الايراني وعناصر من الحرس الثوري ومنعهم
من دخول كندا حفاظا على امن البلاد رفع
السعد
هربوا تاركين بلادهم سعيا للامن والامان
ولم يتوقعوا ان تصلهم تهديدات النظام
الايراني الى كندا يتظاهرون في شوارع
تورنتو كل اسبوع مطالبين الحكومه بمنع
دخول انصار النظام وادراج الحرس الثوري
الايراني على قائمه الارهاب
الكنديين في كندا لذلك فرضنا سلسله عقوبات
جاده
عليهما عن تهديدات بالقتل الايرانيين على
الاراضي الكنديه لم يكشف عن اسمائهم انشطه
شوبراك تتعرض للتهديد بشكل مستمر وحتى
اللحظه
ووالديه عندما جئت الى كندا قررت ان ادافع
عن حقوق المراه وبعدها باشهر بدات
التهديدات ارسلوا لي بريدا قالوا فيه لا
تتوقع انك في امان وسنراقبك حتى ان نعرف
عنوانك كما ذهبوا الى منزلنا واستجوبوا
والدتي
نشيطون الذكر ان تهديد النظام نوعان الاول
مباشر وهذا ينفذ فورا والاخر غير مباشره
عن طريق ارسال الرسائل او تهديدهم
بعائلاتهم وهذا ما حدث مع الصحفي طه
حاول النظام الايراني والتسلل الى الجاليه
بنشاطات مختلفه ثقافيه او دينيه ولم تهتم
الحكومه الكنديه كثيرا بانشطه عملاء
النظام الذين حاولوا تهديدنا حتى انهم
ذهبوا الى منزل عائلتي في ايران لاكف عن
نشاطي قبل نحوي عامين كان لديهم تهديد
المباشر حيث قلت الانشطه سياسي في منطقه
في مدينه باري ولم تقدم الشرطه الكنديه
حتى الان اي تفسيرا حول الجريمه التي مر
عليها نحو 11 شهرا لكن هناك نشيطين نعرفهم
من ورائها
عقوبه طالت شخصيات وكيانات ايرانيه تسعى
من خلالها كندا للحد من دخول انصار النظام
اراضيها واستجابه لمطالب المحتاجين اخرها
عقوبه على مرتضى طلائق قائد شرطه طهران
السابق الذي ظهرت صوره في احدى صاله
الرياضه بكندا
اعترفت بها رسميا ومعتمده على تقارير
مخابراتها وحضرت النظام الايراني
منتدياتها رفع السعد العربيه
افادت مصادر العربيه ان السيارات الاميه
التي تعرضت الانفجار رغم الحوتي في
الحديده كانت تقل رئيس البعثه مايكل بريء
المصادر اكدت نجاه رئيس البعثه باعجوبه من
انفجار اللغم تحت سيارته التي دمرت تماما
معنا من القاهره حول ذلك وكيل وزاره العدل
اليمنيه فيصل المجيد اهلا بك سيد فيصل
معنا غموض وضبابيه يعم هذا الانفجار ولا
تفاصيل من الامم المتحده حتى الان حول ذلك
كيف تفسر هذا الغموض
هذا يضاف الى سلسله الحقيقه الغموضات
السابقه للامم المتحده في ما يتعلق بملف
ستوكرم بشكل عام سبق وان تم اغتيال
الضابط الصليحي وهو كان يعمل تحت امراه
الامم المتحده الامم المتحده يعني لم تقدم
اي تفسير عن هذا الامر مع ان اطلاق النار
كان من جانب الحوثي هذا الحادث اليوم
حقيقه يؤكد بان البعثه الاميه للاسف
الشديد همم تحاول ان تغطي على افعال
الميليشيا الحوثيه الاجراميه يعني للاسف
الشديده اللي هو المتحده منخرطه في دعم ما
يسمى بنزع الاغلاق الحوثيه وهي مع انها
المتسببه في زراعه هذه همم
الالغام يعني تقارير تحدثت عن ان الدعم
وصل الى ما يخالف 170 همم مليون دولار
خلال سنوات الماضيه اضافه الى 420 سياره
دفع رباعي لمليشي الحوثي مع انها الوحيده
وبتقارير الامم المتحده التي تزرع هذه
الالغامه والتقدير التي تتحدث عن ما يقارب
مليونير يعني لهم الوحيد الذي ينزع هذه
الالغام هو مسام او هو المشروع السعودي في
حين ان ميليشي الحوثي المتهم نحن ننتظر
بالفعل بيان من الامم المتحده
هذا الانفجار ربما يخدم كدذير لما يعانيه
اهل الحديده يوميا في حياتهم اليوميه من
اهمال ربما الحوثي كما يصفونه بازاله
مخلفات الحرب
صدقتي
يامر حقيقه اسبوع او ربما كل يوم والا
ونجد اصابات
اليمنيين تتحدث التقارير عن ااا يعني بعض
التقاليد عن اصابه ومقتل ما يقارب 10,000
يمني من اجراء هذه الافعال همم يعني
النساء وصلنا الى بيقارب 641 امراه لاطفال
202 وهي حقيقه ارقام مرعبه بشكل كبير
تحتاج اليمن للتخلص من هذه الالغام الى ما
يقارب الثمان سنوات لكن حقيقه لعل نجاه
همم يعني رئيس البعثه العموميه الايرلندي
وهو الذي تسلم مهامه في يناير 2022 في
بدايات هذا العام همم ترجع الى كوني كان
يستقل سيارته مدرعه لكن ال- المرافقين من
الامنين هناك تتحدث عن قتله واصابات فيما
بينهم احنا نتحدث عن جريمه مستمره منذ
ثمان سنوات
يبقى اليمنيه واضح شكرا لك من القاهره
وكيل وزاره العدل اليمنيه فيصل المجيدي
[موسيقى]
اعلن مكتب الادعاء العام الالماني صدور
اوامر اعتقال ضد 25 شخصا يشتبه بانتمائهم
لجماعه مواطن الرايخ من اقصى اليمين بعد
تفتيش اكثر من 100 موقع في 11 ولايه وذكر
وزير العدل الالماني ان المدعي العام
يحققه مع شبكه ارهابيه خططت لجنه هجمات
المسلحه على مؤسسات الدستوريه من بينها
مجلس النواب البنط ولفت تقارير المانيه
الى ان المتهمين خط طول اضطرابات منهجه
وعنيفه وكان بحوزتهم اسلحه اثناء اعتقالهم
اعتبر مسؤولون غربيون كبار ان الضربات في
العمق الروسيه ستواجه ضرب نفسيه قويه
لموسكو وقال المسؤولون ان الهجوم على
قواعد الجويه روسيه يحتم عليها التفكير
ماليا على كيفيه الحفاظ على سلامه قاضي
فاتها بعيده المدى ووصلت الضربه الى اقصى
عمق داخل الروسي منذ غزلها اوكرانيا في
الرابع
داخل روسيا كما يحلو لهم وهذا سيقلق الروس
بشده من جانبها قالت وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه ان الولايات المتحده لا تمكن او
تشجع اوكرانيا
بعد ان اظهرت اوكرانيا قدره جديده
على اختراق المجال الجويه الروسي بماءات
الكيلومترات على القواعد الجويه
نحن لا نشجع اوكرانيا على هجمات خارج
حدودها كل ما نقوم به وكل تفعله العالم
لدعم اوكرانيا هو الدعم الاستقلال
اوكرانيا وسيادتها وسلامه اراضيها
هولندا اعلنت قبولها العرض الذي طرحته
بيرلين من قبل اسبوعين بنصب بطاريات
صواريخ باتريوت على اراضيها وذلك بعد ان
كانت الحكومه البولنديه قد رفضت هذا العرض
واقترحت على نظيرتها الالمانيه ارسال هذه
المنظومه الدفاعيه الى اوكرانيا
وكان قد اكد قائد قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
مظلومه انا الاداره الامريكيه لم تسمح الى
الان بعمليه تركيه وكشف عبدي عن مضمون
محادثاته مع عقائد القوات الروسيه الذي
زاره في مقره شرق الفرات ووسطته مع انقره
مشيرا الى ان روسيا حاليا في موقف محايد
بينهم وبين تركيا
في تونس تبدا اليوم نقابه اصحاب المخابز
اضرابا مفتوحا بسبب عدم تسديد السلطان في
ذمتها لفائده اعضائها امين ومال النقابه
الصادق الحبوبي اكد في تصريح للحدث عدم
التراجع عن تنفيذ الاضراب المقرر باعتبار
اصحاب المخابز بيت المهددين بالافلاس على
خلفيه ارتفاعي تكلفه صناعه الخبز مقارنه
اصحاب المخابز وزاره التجاره بتسديد
الديون والتي تقدر بنحو 75 مليون دولار
بعنوان الفارق بين صناعه الخبز وبيعه طيله
14 شهرا ماضيه حقق المنتخب المغربي
المشاهدين انجازا تاريخيا في تاهله لدور
الثمانيه في مونديال قطر بعد فوزه تاريخي
على المنتخب الاسباني بركلات الترجيح
وبذلك يكون اول منتخب عربي يتاهل لدور
الثمانيه وسيلتقي المنتخب المغربي المنتخب
البرتغالي التي فازت على سويسرا بحصه
ثقيله
هذا واستطاعت العربيه او استطلاعت اراء
الشارع المغربي بعد انتصار المغرب على
اسبانيا في دور ثمن النهائي والتاهل
التاريخي لاول مره الى دور ربع النهائي
لكاس العالم
بزاف بزاف بزاف بزاف ونتمنى لهم ان شاء
الله المسيره تكون طويله
[موسيقى]
في جزيره مارجريتا البنزليه في البحر
الكاريبي وجد الروس متنفسن سياحيا جديدا
بعد ان ضاقت عليهم الوجوهات الاخرى بسبب
العقوبات الغربيه على بلادهم
ذراعها كما تفعل هذه المدينه وبلاد اخرى
قليله هنا يطيب المقام
فلما ضاقت عليهم وجدها هؤلاء في هذه
الجزيره البنزويليه استقبالا دافئا ومفعما
ايضا انها جزيره مارجريتا في البحر
الكاريبي
الجزيره باتت وجهه للرؤوس وثلاثه الاف مرو
من هنا في الشهرين الماضيين لكن لماذا
فنزويلا
تلقي العقوبات الغربيه
السياحيه فهذه الجزيره اصبحت وجهه مباشره
من روسيا اليها اضافه الى تكاليف منخفضه
فهي ارخص من مدينه سوتشي جنوبيه روسيا
وهذا ما يشجع فنزويلا لاستقداد الروس ابتس
على استقبال نحو مئه الف سائح منهم حتى
نهايه العام الجاري
الاخبار الاقتصاد مع زميل الناصر
ارقام اسواق جلسه هذا اليوم حيث تتعمق
الخسائر في السوق السعوديه الى قرابه
الواحد في المئه انخفضت السوق الان دون ال
10,400 نقطه نذكركم طبعا السوق السعوديه
كانت عندكم رابط 12000 نقطه في نهايه شهر
اكتوبر لكن على مدار اكثر من خمسه اسابيع
متتاليه كان هناك تراجعات واضحه في السوق
تزامنت مع انتهاء فتره الافصاحات عن نتائج
الشركات الربع الثالث وتزامنت ايضا مع
الانخفاضات في اسعار النفط حيث نلحظ اليوم
اسعار برنت دون عتبه الثمانين دولار
للبرنيه المؤشر السوق اذا متراجع بواحد في
المئه في باقي اسواق الخليج نشهد ايضا بعض
التراجعات لكنها نسب التراجعات اقل همم
نوعا ما الاسهم الاكثر تداولا في السعوديه
مرافق بسته اعشار النقطه المئويه لاحظوا
البنوك مره ده هي التي تقود الانخفاضات
كما قادتها مطلع هذا الاسبوع الراجحي
والاهلي تراجعات بواحد ونصف النقطه
المئويه اما في سوق دبي فنلحق تراجع الان
على سهم اعمار الى سته دراهم و20 فلس لكن
في القطاع العقاري ديار على مكاسب بواحد
وعشر النقطه المئويه في ابو ظبي طبعا حيث
نسمع بانه ايدي كيو والدار العقاريه همم
يع زمان على همم تقديم عرض للاستحواذ على
مجموعه جيمس التعليميه ومقرها دبي نلحظ
ملط بلاي هو السهم الاكثر نشاطا ومن ثم
اتش سي على استقرار كلاهما ماء للتراجع
طاقه تعمر خسارها لا اكثر من ثلاثه ونصف
نقطه المئويه اما في السوق الكويتيه
التراجع ايضا مستمر بعد انخفاضات البارحه
مؤشر الكويت الاول باثنين في المئه البنك
المركزي الكويتي مساء البارحه قام سياده
نسبه الفائده ب 50 نقطه اساس الى ثلاثه
ونصف النقطه المئويه البنوك متراجعه اليوم
بيتك والوطني انخفضات بحوالي ثلاثه اعشار
النقطه المئويه ولكن الافكو على مكاسب
باربعه ونصف النقطه المئويه الافكو على
مسار تصاعدي خلال تقريبا اسبوعين الماضيين
بعد اعلان الشركه بانها تدرس همم عرض همم
بيع اصولها الى شركه مكواري همم في همم
طبعا همم في استراليا بقيمه اصول تصل هذه
الصفقه الى اكثر من اثنين مليار دولار هذه
كانت وقفتنا على اسواق مشاهدينا
نعود الان من جديد الى الرياض والى
الزميله فاطمه
مشاهد صور مباشره معكم مشاهدينا لعمليه
مداهمات واسعه بحثا للشرطه الالمانيه عن
عناصر من اقصى اليمين خط طول هجمات
المسلحه على مواقع سياديه بينها البرلمان
نهايه النشره الى العناوين
الرئيس الصينيه
للسعوديه تستمر ثلاثه ايام من ويتخللها
قيمتان خليجيه وعربيه
بعد حل شرطه الاخلاق هامني ان يحاول تهدئه
الاحتجاجات مجددا ويدعو الاصلاح النظام
الثقفي
مصادر تكشف للعربيه رئيس البعثه الامميه
في الحديده ناجي اعجوبه من انفجار لغم
الحوثي تحت سيارته
في امان الله
[موسيقى]